[MUSIC]
Being able to work on group projects,
being able to practice role-plays with my
classmates, being able to provide and
receive direct feedback.
All these require me to
work with other people.
All of these require me to get
outside my comfort zone and learn and
stretch and grow.
[MUSIC]
>> Being a student in my classrooms
at the GSB is not a spectator sport.
[MUSIC]
>> Their notion is that, depending on the
kind of class we have, the instructor, and
the goals, that they pick the pedagogy
that works best for them.
[MUSIC]
>> Professor Grousbeck,
who is a serious entrepreneur,
founded probably 15 companies in his life.
>> Make sure you understand-
>> Role-playing with him, how to fire and
hire people, being respectful but
still direct,
was one of the most
amazing experiences I had.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]
>> If you're learning something
which is more hardcore,
you really need a lecture-based approach
to kind of soak in the information.
>> I teach a class in our core which we
call Foundations on Management Accounting.
And they wanted to figure out which
product actually makes the money, right,
they had no idea.
Given the nature of the material,
much of what I do is lecture.
>> And then you have all these projects
where you apply this information.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Very,
very transformational idea that came
across in the lecture that I really value.
[MUSIC]
>> Feedback is one of the core components
of the Stanford GSB experience.
>> And
you're hit with it really from day one
>> When this situation occurred,
here's how you reacted, and
here's how that came off.
>> And then you receive feedback on
how the feedback you gave landed.
>> What that allowed me to do was go
back and fix those specific behaviors.
>> So if you think about
becoming a manager someday,
that's really important to know,
how your feedback comes across.
[MUSIC]
>> From the global study trip, I think the
one thing I'll never forget is probably
meeting the sitting president of Rwanda.
Paul Kagame, the man who's credited for
ending the genocide.
[MUSIC]
>> The interplay between the two of them,
the back and forth.
And sometimes hearing
the different perspectives
was hugely helpful in informing
how I think about business.
What I want to do, who I want to be,
and how I want to react.
>> The one thing that GSB stresses is that
we don't want to be wedded to any one
particular method.
[MUSIC]
>> By far my best experience
was a simulation of the UN with
Professor Condoleezza Rice,
as part of her global class.
>> It was about the European crisis.
>> We actually represented Russia.
>> I, being from Germany,
had to play Greece against Germany.
>> 48 hours later, we presented to
the former secretary of the state.
>> It was just, it was amazing.
[MUSIC]
>> If you're going to learn how to
exercise judgment in the context of
complex situation, to me,
cases is the best way to do it.
>> Okay, yeah.
>> What might you do to try to negotiate?
>> I think that's a way to buy some time.
>> Buy some time,
how much it going to cost?
>> We use the case as
a platform to role-play and
to discuss management issues.
>> And that is so helpful, because
they bring the context, the situation,
the milieu that the case
was actually involved in.
And that's something that's
missing in just case, hard fact.
>> And though we might have studied
the case before with the best
solution in mind.
Once we got there and saw the facts on the
ground, the reality was much different.
>> Let me also just go
through the question.
What was the problem, quickly?
[MUSIC]
>> When I was accepted at Stanford, one of
the first things I did was to figure out
how I could into Extreme Affordability.
So we come in, and we actually
take all these different ideas.
And when one idea comes in that's
very eccentric or wild and
loud, it actually spurs an idea that's
a little more acceptable and meaningful.
>> The rest of these are really nice
solutions to ethical problems, but
that one kind of like-
>> And
then pretty soon we find ourselves
going down this path together,
even though we're from various different
backgrounds, to solve this common need.
I think it's really opened my eyes to some
of the interesting insights that can come
out of students from the law school,
students from the medical school.
It's been fantastic.
>> The students are always
getting cutting-edge knowledge.
There are always classes being taught here
that would never be taught anywhere else.
Because no one else is even thinking
about the application of what
we're doing to business.
>> I wish I could take all the knowledge
I've learned in the last year and a half.
Have that with me, and go back and
do this experience all over again.
>> There is no question
that it's more engaging.
[MUSIC]